um
well you know how what about daylight
savings
let's get rid of that
what a bunch of crap once a year
it comes up and then there's a movement
where everybody complains about it and
then you have like some weirdo
politician who's like on my sole
platform i'm going to run on the sole
platform of like getting rid of this and
then then we forget about it and i'm
sure it's been talked about the podcast
but why does it not happen that we don't
want it nobody wants it nobody likes it
somebody
somebody that's what we keep hearing why
the [ __ ] would a farmer like it farmers
like oh i got to get up on it earlier
even earlier
what is
what is going on the sun's not changing
word change what are we doing what is
i don't know what is it we got hot for a
second that was pretty good
i think we should have a whole call-in
show
about whether or not about whether or
not like truly what is going on with
i'll tell you what if you're a
politician and you're running on
daylight savings that's gonna well i
think it's more of a joke i think it's
more of a joke but it actually does rile
people up
because no they're not talking to
anybody have you ever talked to one
person who's like man i'm super psyched
about about changing them clocks
are you're one of them well i like to
fall back
i like to fall back you like that extra
sleep but don't you don't shower asleep
yeah but you like getting for one day i
don't like springing forward
like that but you like looking at your
clock and you're like oh it's 4 30 all
the sun just went down
no yeah right okay well nobody likes
that well then okay so that but that's
the vast majority of it you just but
it's all worth it for the one day but
i'm also not a huge fan of the sun
that's not clear from my complexion so
we should get rid of the sun
i do sort of feel like that's that's the
real problem is the sun i mean you know
what i mean we we're headed that way we
are headed to
to people wanting to cancel the sun
being like it it gives you [ __ ]
cancer enough in the sun yeah right
enough of this sun let's cancel the sun
let's get rid of it
that's where we're going yeah i like
that plan
well look the sun does give you cancer
it also gives us life
let's learn to live with the sun guys
right but what is the daylight savings
time giving us it's giving us nothing no
i'm with you guys i think it should be
around and every year
it's a it's a topic of conversation for
a couple of days people get riled up you
see it on social media everyone's like
why are we doing this again and then
someone else is like well actually the
reason why we're doing it
and nobody gives a [ __ ] oh
nobody gives a [ __ ] now was that a
scientist what was it a science [ __ ]
trying to make is that a stupid
scientist
this is me pretending to know what i'm
talking about which i don't yes
right well you do i mean you're a person
living in a person that has an opinion
and i'm sure there is a valid reason out
there and every year i'm like i'm going
to look it up and then i'm like i don't
know
oh yeah isn't there like a state that
doesn't like arizona yeah there's some
places that don't there are some places
that don't do it which you know kind of
proves your point to a degree which is
then even more confusing as we become
more of a
a connected society all over the world
where like the time zones of like what
time is it there yeah it's chaos it's
chaos i i think you should do a deep
dive on it and really try to figure out
the reason for it okay right really
weigh the pros and cons in an educated
and then let's have a call in show
right yeah you know not about daylight
savings but well listen to the caller we
have to have some structure to that
because that was that was fun but it was
it was chaos it was chaos which is okay
for the first one but now i think we
have to yeah well we'll we'll we'll come
up with something that people can
specifically ask us that will be
entertaining to hear people asking i
think if we had a call-in show about
daylight savings there wouldn't be
enough conflict well i think you're
going to have 100 of the audience i
agree i agree why are we doing this this
is the dumbest thing ever yeah yeah well
you know you know what's entertaining
getting help hostage
[Music]
i love this episode it's interesting so
uh
it's interesting i i remember loving
this episode i remember hating it oh
yeah i always loved this episode i
always loved it and last night i watched
it and i was like no i still like it i i
still think it's funny but
i don't know i mean it's our first
depart departure episode right the first
time we took the format of the show and
well
i did it like because it's almost yeah
you know using different
and truly at this point the characters
are not real human beings well so we're
presenting people who are
actively like
trying to get the other characters
killed yeah right which is like it's a
bit broad it's raw it's super broad and
i remember at the time being like is
this really the direction of the show
when it turned out yes yeah and for good
reason yeah yeah um so
i i saw one of those lists like um
i don't know it's like collider or
something of like best
episode from each season and for this
season they had picked the gang gets
held hostage
interesting i don't agree well i don't
agree i don't think it's our best
episode i i was
kind of like meh but i laughed enough
that i made it work
but i was also like what are what were
we doing i enjoyed it i almost enjoyed
it more for nostalgic purposes like i i
i cause i because i loved that episode
so much when we were making it and when
we were editing it although i do
remember that one the problem was we got
in the editing room we put that episode
together and we were like this does not
work at all
and that because we're using sunny music
yeah we're using the same music we
always use and we realized we're like
we just did it as an experiment we were
like why don't you just take a bunch of
action movie music and we had our editor
just cut a version with a bunch of
action movie music in it and all of a
sudden it worked yeah i did think about
that watching it about how the creative
process
leads you often like we don't go in
there necessarily saying we're going to
do something with action music
sometimes we do sometimes we have a very
specific idea like that like this ski
episode where we're like we're going to
spoof those ski movies and we'll
probably use ski movie music and movie
but for this one it was just like we're
going to tell a story about this
happening and we're going to reference
die hard a little bit and then we get in
the editing room and we're like well we
just can't use our
regular music it doesn't work yeah so we
have to search around we find something
that works and then
and then that becomes the reality for
that you know that's that's how we we
get there we don't really have sort of
some preconceived idea of how we're
going to get there it's just we keep
trying things and then what seems to be
right reveals itself to us i don't know
if that's interesting to listen to no it
isn't man i i think i do think i mean
it's also it is interesting though how
much music really does influence your
experience of something oh yeah yeah uh
i mean do you ever see those cuts where
they i know you have where they take
like the shining yeah yeah and then they
like they cut it to peter gabriel's uh
salt reel
or they take out a laugh track on
certain sitcoms even if it comes oh
that's great right that's great seinfeld
or friends like shows i love when i love
them they take the laugh track out it's
just big holes this is so weird
yeah that's it's great that idea that
necessity drives innovation to a certain
point right where you're like well
we we [ __ ] this up and now it's
necessary for us to try to fix it and
then we
figure out a different way maybe we
should put a different soundtrack over
covid you know what i mean just put a
different soundtrack over it what is the
soundtrack of covid well i think the
soundtrack of covert right now is like
maybe
maybe maybe you can
i don't know maybe you can shine shine a
little sunshine on lighten up all the
death
yeah or focus on the positive parts of
it all the people that lived yeah look
at all the people that live okay
so many people lived
um i don't know i mean just a thought
you know maybe maybe if when we talk
about covert on the news
you know we play like something jolly in
the background like like christmas music
and [ __ ] you know or do it without do it
with war
do it with social turmoil right like
that's what we did with sunny in the
beginning we were like well how this is
dark if we go dark with it it's not
going to work so let's lighten it up
let's play leave it to beaver music and
it works so it works on it let's do it
on the news let's do it on let's do it
on the next do it on the news
everyone'll be more reliable people
[ __ ] children let's really [ __ ] with
people and when they tell good news
like we've cured cancer but it's like
you know what i mean something else is
going to pop up or whatever yeah
yeah you never know what does that mean
yeah uh there's a note with that
there's a thing where the guns are
rubber at the end yeah but there's a
thing where dee grabs yeah
and it's so real so i guess you'd have
to be like well there was like one kind
of prop for realist gun and the other
one was rubber okay do you remember this
i think it was this episode i think it
was this episode where we got to the
editing room
and we had slowed down that footage yeah
and where yesterday's
right and so it's really funny he falls
to the ground and he told us hilarious
so we're in the like mix studio or
whatever and we're like okay great so we
want to slow down
i do remember this i remember and then
and the guy was like we can't do that it
can't be done it just can't be done and
we were like no no it can be done like
you slower
to match what's happening nah that's
just like no that's that's just like not
that's like
it was like unbelievable we're not
making that up we've stole or we're
stealing it from yeah yeah things we've
seen no it's only been done a thousand
times yes
yeah yeah has it not been done here
because it's like but like well this is
a man whose job it is to
do sam's stuff yeah and it kept coming
out like no
you know
like well not that not whatever that is
like the thing you've heard in the movie
it is amazing how often that that will
happen where people are like oh this is
just not possible oh no my biggest pet
beef is on set where you a character has
a microphone and so some sound guy's
like so we'll put in the echo effect in
the room after so let's not actually
have the microphone on and then they
can't do it it's like just turn the
[ __ ] microphone on and we'll record
that yeah an example of that is also in
this episode too where you can clearly
hear that i'm off camera talking to
frank in the walkie-talkie yeah and i
remember that was real like i was just
off camera actually doing it and i
remember the ever this big discussion of
the caption being like well we'll just
put it in later i'm like why would we do
that why don't we just do it right now
yeah just you haven't holding a
walkie-talkie well you can hear it
anytime someone's just going to look
like something later or a sound or look
like something i'm always like no let's
just make it sound and look like it now
yes and so that i know we
like when people are like oh well that's
not going to look like that but
it does look like it i can see it
just destroying the illusion of
hollywood for a second when somebody
walks in with a with a paper bag
just just so you're all aware of it i
love that the grocery paper bag anytime
you see one on tv or movies except for
on our show it is made out of this
material that that is on of this earth
it's like amazing materials
it's some kind of like plastic it's not
a real bag and the reason is because at
some point the sound department colluded
with the
department and said we can't have real
bags on the set because they crinkle and
they make too much noise they sound like
that they sound like bags so what we'll
do is we'll have you get these fake ones
that don't really upon inspection don't
really look like it and also don't have
the properties of a bag so they don't
look like a bag and then we'll we'll put
it in post so all the sounds that you
could get will pay for later
to add in to not actually have them on
set right why
why
remember the reason we had the boom guy
who like either always had a cold a
perpetual cold or we've talked about
this on the podcast yeah yeah
no we haven't we haven't i don't know i
don't know what to say
but that's different than we've talked
about this before i'm saying we've
actually talked about this on a podcast
yes i never want to challenge what we
have or have no argument for me if you
tell me we haven't i'm sure that we have
and by the way i still i i'd be down to
hear that story again because it makes
me [ __ ] laugh i think it's
hilarious it you got the choice
yeah that was no but yeah that was no
but yeah no but as opposed to nasa well
it was
no we already it was what it was
all right yeah no we already yeah which
is fine yeah
so you already said that line man you
don't need to say it again yeah yeah i i
i do enjoy the adr in this episode too i
caught two adr go ahead well where there
were two of them okay i i kind of want
to challenge the the audience and i like
okay so
it's it it's one one of them is my line
and one of them is jimmy's line and it
might be interesting to see if people
can identify it because it was clear to
me
because adr is always like
clear if you know if you remember it and
yeah and they i don't know if the
audience would know
okay so you're going to challenge the
audience to try to pick out those adr
moments yeah uh did but was it does it
pop out enough to where people are
actually going to be able to pick out
that that was not production i don't
know well maybe that's a that's a good
oh you guys didn't pick up on it again
so maybe that's a good sign that it was
well
i don't know that it's that i didn't
pick up on it as much as i didn't feel
like it was worthy to talk about but
i'm not saying it isn't i'm not saying
it oh you touched his hand you touched
rob's hand and it it's so uncommon for
you guys to touch me i don't mind being
touched yeah me either and i like i like
touching i i but i feel like whenever i
touch
definitely charlotte which we talked
about yeah but glenn even
isn't it funny how like i feel like of
the three of us like you're the most
approachable and sort of like the the
most lovable the most lovable of the
three of us and yet like uh and i'm
probably the least and yet like in real
life i enjoy touch i think more than
even you guys definitely more than you
maybe even more that might be afraid of
your touch
i think when people meet me in real life
they can feel that my energy isn't quite
what it is when they
i always expect like if i get approached
by a fan of the show like i always
expect them to be a little like
is this guy going to yell at me you know
and you might but they don't well i
might but it won't be because it won't
be because you're it won't be because
you're nice it'll be because you're a
dick but like you know i but people
actually don't feel that way around me
and i i and i i appreciate that i i
don't know if that's you're in their
homes man you're in their living room
but they come right up and just touch
you
no no that that that would be a little a
little bit strange although i i'd be
more open to it than you'd think like
if if covid weren't such a thing
you know what i mean and somebody like
like a fan came up and was like oh my
god i i really like your show can i give
you a hug [ __ ] yeah let's do it i hug
fans all the time i'm a hugger
i'm fine with the mutually accepted
touch situation that's when it comes out
it's more when it comes out i'm just
easily startled you know i'm like okay
right you're like so like you know like
uh i don't know
you're like a cobra
yeah i was gonna see more like a muskrat
both are ready to strike at any moment
right yeah i'm ready i'm more ready to
scramble than i am right
all right
i'm ready to scramble yeah i'd get out
of st in a hostage situation i'd find
the first window and be out fast you
know i could get out faster that's what
you'd do in a hostage situation what if
your friends weren't dating i don't want
to know have you ever had a gun pointed
at you in real life
uh
no god no i mean other than on a set no
i have
really yeah my next door next gun was it
loaded i didn't ask yeah yeah that's
just doesn't matter
it does matter but the rule is you're
supposed to assume that i was a child
uh and like you know i'm 12 11. and i
think we were riding our bikes to our
friend's house and i had this crazy
neighbor man and uh
i guess i rode my bike too close to his
truck or whatever and he pulled a
shotgun out
pointed at me and my friends and goes i
can make you all fade
that's a great [ __ ] line yeah
we're like oh [ __ ] man what was that wow
i don't know i don't know why he had a
country accent in rhode island but he
did he did yeah he was probably on the
on the lamb you know he's probably
hiding out oh yeah yeah yeah he was he
was on a lamb
he was on a lamb he was on the lamb
which just means when you're when you
eat lamb and you're like on the lamb
right you know what that means
i've had a knife pulled on me too i had
a nice pull on me once yeah yeah yeah
not but yeah in a mugging situation but
it never came anywhere you've been
mugged i've been mugged i've been mugged
twice
well also like
i've been beaten up a bunch but that was
less like it's this is about about your
getting your money and that was the the
muggings were never violent because i
just gave them the thing right because
what's worked but then i've been like
jump you've been jumped before i've
never been jumped oh really no
i jumped you've never been jumped or
mugged
i've been mugged i've never been jumped
what's the difference between being
jumped and being well when you're just
someone wants some money from you when
you jump someone just wants to kick they
start beating throughout
your house yeah yeah yeah and the
mugging you don't really deserve
sometimes the the no you know no you
don't deserve
on the wildwood boardwalk like a group a
group of kids
yeah yeah yeah for for fun what is this
not for me is
yeah yeah south jersey board the border
wildwood wildwood new jersey oh right
right right okay yeah the wild wood
boardwalk yeah yeah group of young uh
[Laughter]
[Applause]
foot keeps slipping right off him
we should wipe our fish on him i'm
trying to punch you but the bunch is
sliding
i was on a bike it was even weirder i
was like on a bike and i was like trying
to get out these are total strangers
total strangers and they just decided
yeah how old were you
14 i was a freshman in high school how
bad was the beat down like how bad did
it get it wasn't terrible it wasn't
great i just remember like i had a bike
and i was like oh and then some kid came
up and was like hey give me some money
and i was like i don't have any which i
didn't but rather and then i could tell
like
i was being surrounded and i was like oh
good and then there's people everywhere
it's the boardwalk in the summer
the kid i try to move and he the kid
sticks his foot like in the spokes just
like stop it and stopped it and then he
was gonna [ __ ] him up well he was like
ow and then some other guy's like did
you did you just
hurt my brother and i was like no i was
just trying i'm like now i'm getting my
i know i'm getting beat up yeah you know
and then i just like turn and the kid
whose foot like who put it in the front
just [ __ ] clocked me right off the
did they steal your bike no so that's
why it's not a mug then they kind of
stomped on me a little bit and then of
course they're well like kicked me and
whatnot right no again nothing like
serious because we're in i mean there
was thousands of people on the boardwalk
yeah and then eventually someone's like
hey what are you doing over there and
then would it yeah yeah do it what are
these kids doing i saw a crazy fight
when i was in australia and it was um
like their national like their fourth of
july i think it's called australia day
and uh there were like these teenagers
right outside my house and they were
like a couple of them were beating up on
this one kid
and i thought all right i gotta i gotta
go down there and like break it up or
something right like i was like i gotta
maybe they'll recognize me and they'll
stop fighting for a second so when was
this
this was how long ago we were talking
about um
five years ago or something i was in i
was doing specific room two and a half
oh right right so um yeah
and then i realized
those kids are gonna kick the living
[ __ ] out of me like that weird feeling
of like oh wait wait wait wait i'm now
at the age where those teenagers
they're they're stronger than me they
got more energy more testosterone
testosterone thing kick the [ __ ] out of
me yeah but i did start making my way
downstairs and by the time i i was i saw
them from like an upstairs window of
this house i was renting by the time i
got down they were they were going they
dispersed it was a pretty
last time i saw like a good brawl
happening that's an australian thing
though oh yeah i mean let's not be too
stereotypical but every australian guy
some fan mate yeah it's fun mate
next
your next rock you're gonna be my next
bit of fun
uh yeah [ __ ] your head
brutal yeah no yeah so but and then the
knife like in new york someone showed me
a knife and i was like what what do you
need what do you need i need i'll give
it to you i remember yeah i got mugged i
was with my buddy sam witwer we were it
was after a birthday party we were at
like right near the roosevelt hotel
and beautiful part of these guys yeah
these guys pulled up and you know got
out of the car oh it's kind of a similar
situation they were like you were like
yo you got 20 bucks and and i was like
no what are you talking about and then
they pulled the car over and i was like
oh [ __ ] i actually have that twenty
dollars that you you know what i
mentioned
i just realized i do have that uh is
there any way that that's all you're
gonna take from me
um you know yeah it's the same thing i
pulled out a knife and uh and uh you
know i i remember i distinctly remember
i pulled my wallet out and i opened it
because it was a wallet where you could
see the cash on the inside and i pulled
because i was like i want them to take
my wallet i gotta replace my license
replace my credit cards it's gonna be a
whole thing so i just very like i showed
them took all the cash out and was like
boom and i just got to the [ __ ] atm
man it was like they got like 300 bucks
off me it was a good it was a good get
it was a good get but and then and then
it wasn't until afterwards that it like
really dawned on me i'm like
man what if that had been like a like an
initiation type situation you know what
i mean where it was like not really
about little we'll get let's get their
money but also like
you know this guy's been he's being
initiated into you know this gang and so
he has to stab you
you know maybe there's even an apology
an apology that goes before the
stabbings i'm sorry man my friend has to
stab you which would have made it maybe
slightly better
you know what i mean it's like we don't
have a choice here we don't have a
choice there's a reason for it that'll
be worse because if you knew it was
coming i'd rather be stabbed without
knowing it right
yeah yeah yeah no you're right he's like
sorry i'm about to stab you yeah you're
like oh [ __ ] yeah you're anticipating it
that's like that amazing speaking of uh
spielberg always comes in here and he's
got that amazing scene and uh saving
private ryan where oh the guy's like
just no no no don't do this you don't
have to stab me don't he like
don't like let's just go our separate
ways yeah and he's like nah nah man i
gotta i gotta do this yeah i wonder what
that was like shooting that
where what do
what do you think it was like shooting
that scene we should talk to we should
find out from stevenson i think there
was like
standing over him
do you want to see if steven's around
and we can
seem forced yeah i don't want to force
it he's got to let it happen sorry you
know what i mean he never he you can't
schedule him he's like
you know he's out about doing his thing
and then every once in a while you get
lucky pops in you know yeah yeah you
just can't force it
[Music]
can i ask you guys a question so let's
say you arrived for the podcast today
and you know how i come a little bit
early to like get set up
you came in and the door's locked and
you find out that i've been taken
hostage
and that the hostage taker wants to talk
to one of you
so who among you do you think is the
best hostage negotiator are we talking
through the door are we coming in i
guess it doesn't matter that much uh
let's say you're coming in but only one
basically he's got you in this room
he's holding you hostage and he and
we're out there and he's calling out
saying i need to talk to one of you but
you guys get to pick who you're sending
in right who's the one i'm sending in
charlie
well i would say you know you and rob
spend the most time together with the
extra work you guys do on mythicquest
and i have to be at el salvador by 11
30.
so right so i probably said it and robin
hitting the road just so i could beat
the traffic
well the traffic's bad i mean the
driving's back
on the 405. super bowl sunday it's gonna
be hard to get if you're from la you can
understand that yeah rob why don't you
hop in there and then i'm gonna i'm
gonna get a head start on my commute
that way i can get there and have a
little bite to eat before we you know
get started i'll tell you what if you
need me to call in i'll call you from
the road uh no i think to okay but
to honestly answer your question to like
have a rational conversation to like
de-escalate situation
[Music]
uh i think i'm a good de-escalator yeah
i think i'll be charlie i think i'm good
at understanding
people's needs and wants and trying to
communicate to those specifically and
talk talk someone down
yeah from a crazy sitch yeah but
you know i don't know god forbid i don't
want to be in that situation you know
who do you think would be the worst
negotiator of the three of you
you know
i think glenn i think you would be here
you'd be irritated with the person you'd
be like okay sir
no wait wait wait wait well hold on a
second let's look at let's look at the
three of us and the relationship that
we've had over the last 15 years
and think about all the arguments that
you two have gotten through and guess
who's right in the middle of it going i
hear you and i hear you
let's find some i'm i'm almost always
the hostage negotiator
in those situations where it's like we
can we can we don't have to get it's
you're smart you're smart you're funny
you're funny let's figure this out
yeah yeah that's that it's a lot it is a
lot of that it's like it's i don't know
i feel like i've been in the middle i
can understand what you're doing okay we
can agree that i would not be the best
one it sounds like that's what you're
doing i actually think you'd be great
well look at this
i mean i'm gonna throw i i i i think you
i think you know what i think for the
greatest success all three of us got to
talk that's right and weigh in with our
opinions this is
i mean it depends on what he's doing is
he is he trying to rob a bank because
then he'd be like a robber yeah but if
he was just taking hostages
hans gruber would be a terrorist
he wasn't a terrorist the hospital
the hostage
the hostager this guy did there's gotta
be a word for it what were you gonna say
about hans gruber well in the movie die
hard which we would in the movie that
we're parodying with frank there uh die
hard hans gruber they think he is a
terrorist at first because he has like
political prisoners that he puts on his
list of demands but it turns out he's
not he's just a thief yeah
yeah good stuff he transitions from
no i'm serious it's a great movie yeah
holds up totally holds up glenn you and
your underwear when you when you d-robe
was a good solid laugh for me
just the way you're kind of holding your
body and the size underwear that we
picked and your willingness to just like
make that funny you know what i mean
like
it was awesome yeah
yeah i remember i was talking about how
we uh all of us acknowledging that it
would be funnier if they were tighty
whities funnier if they were
you know if they were pulled up a little
too high
you know what i mean and then and then
and then as far as the posture goes
there was just something funny about
like shoulders back yeah shoulders back
like you know just
there's something sort of
like serpentine about it or something i
don't know yeah but yeah i i do remember
like sort of very specifically like
picking that look
and just knowing like that that that was
gonna be something funny about it i also
do enjoy that i say that like i want her
inside me yeah
i like when you tell her that we're in
love now and like we've done it right
now there we go
now now we do the thing where you get me
out of here yeah yeah
i did like that part yeah i enjoyed that
too i also enjoyed i also enjoyed your
your scene with frank i i like the the
the han i remember having this
conversation about which way the hands
yes i remember having this conversation
with you we were doing the scene we're
working on the scene and i just i i had
this vision of like old
horror fire movies yes old like dracula
movies from like back in the day and
their hands were were always like it was
like this you know one was up and
forward and one on one was down and so
it was like this yes like this wicked
kind of thing
and uh
i'm very glad we did that we never we
never went back up into that bad room
did we we we kind of ditched that no we
should explore that again at one point
we
and mac and charlie die were kind of in
the guts of the building again
and there's so many rooms above that bar
we're never up there yes
okay and don't we say in the episode
that we're going to the bar of that
we're going to the roof of paddy's he
says we're going up to the roof but we
don't go up to the roof we go up to the
roof of the building next door next door
to us which is kind of a fun mislead so
when he drops you know yes of course
that joke lands but
yeah yeah yeah but but the reason we did
it was because
we weren't allowed on the roof of that
building and we were allowed on the roof
of the building next to it yeah was is
the paddy's building like two it's too
high up right it's like higher up it's
very high up yeah yeah yeah and he would
have died yeah yeah the character would
have died
i got a question for you guys what
what was the genesis i don't remember
what the genesis is
i bet i bet that this is a situation
where we had a card on the board that
said stockholm syndrome
and that someone thought
it was funny 100 percent that is it no
that is what happened is it yeah i was
going to say absolutely someone was like
stockholm syndrome is a funny thing and
that was lisa i think that was lisa
parsons idea i think you're right that
was her idea and
because i felt like we were leaning
really hard in the episode to like
explain stockholm to germany and i was
like
we're over doing that but it's fun yeah
yeah there's a there's a bunch of
exposition and we lean into it by having
the other character being like in fact
you do it in the bathroom where you're
like so what's going on and i start to
explain it and you're like let's go
let's go let's go
and i'm bored i'm bored i'm bored i
don't care and then i just like break it
down yeah yeah yeah that's some good
[ __ ] yeah i mean you had some
interesting exposition in the very first
scene in the back office
when you're you're you're essentially
you're trying to explain to the audience
like you're basically
it's like somewhere along the way
somebody went the audience is going to
wonder why he's got to go up there to
actually get the will when he could just
sit down with a lawyer and redraft a new
version
and so you actually have that
conversation with them yes
frank why don't you just sit down with a
lawyer and you know have him redraft the
wedding he's like don't
don't ask too many questions
it doesn't matter yeah in the audience
basically the audience doesn't care just
get them up into the goddamn match
shutting down that one guy in the
audience is like wait why is he doing
they see it in the uh rob how did we do
the fart in your face were you looking
into my butt
yeah
he didn't have his undies down no no no
i don't think you've got no i don't
think you had your your undies down i
don't think i don't think so god that
would have been great i just remember
what was great was that why the hell
else then do you see the side of my
cheek like that
i didn't i didn't look again i didn't
look so cause maybe i was you must have
been looking directly into my butt
but i definitely remember in the edit
because i couldn't see your face
but like your face is the funniest part
of it yeah right because you enjoy it
the audience knowing that like what yeah
seeing that time yes and then
whatever it was we had an idea where
yeah like you wouldn't see me and then i
would like uh-huh oh yeah my head out
right you know for a line and then come
back and i know that's in the bloopers
very we're very happy with the fart
noise that we chose the squeaky camera
pretty good squeaky airy one rather than
a than a rumbling one
yeah yeah yeah sorry
it's always interesting and whenever
like the idea of like putting a fart in
comes up you see rob go
you know there's just this part of you
is like you you you don't like it but
you recognize that it's funny and you
know where it's needed and you're
willing to do it but you don't really
like it well
normally if our joke is pretty damn lazy
and not so great but in this it's a good
setup for a fart joke it's a good
a fart as revenge
is funnier than just
but also as you say in the episode
you're like
and we might die and i never got to find
you that's right yes so this is
something he's been heartbroken
just wish fulfillment yes it's wishful
for us
you know fantasizing about for a very
long time and you've never gotten to do
it and you're like i never got to do it
and yeah
i think that was improvised some of them
i don't think that was in the script i
don't know i don't remember for sure but
also at the at the very end um
when
and just like every episode
at this time period we just end it um
just so abruptly and we
we realize there's no police outside and
we're like what
what is this what was all this and all
he says is nobody messes with the
mcpoyles yeah and that was it that was
the whole point of the entire episode we
shouldn't we should we probably should
have put in something about like this is
for this this is for doyle yeah so that
people knew what the [ __ ] revenge it was
it was only
two episodes earlier yeah that's true um
i will say that i caught that too or i
was like oh we were connecting things in
this season
which we didn't really do again for
quite some time like little bits here
and there but you know we're connecting
the will and barbara dying and where the
money's gonna go and that's right yeah
yeah no i i like that i mean there there
should be a little bit of continuity to
that to that story especially when
there's like big life things that that
happen i mean especially but then we got
into like a thing just for the listener
at home that we would make the episodes
and then the network would kind of weigh
in oh we want this one to go first and
this one and so we started to lean away
from
connecting them too much just in case
one came out great and we weren't
opposed to their approach they always
wanted to front load the best episodes
because they figured that was the best
way it's going to get the most few
owners and yeah they weren't wrong right
so if we made 10 and one was amazing
we're like yeah well let's get in the
first one or two you know yeah but um
i think we also got a great note from
them after this episode which i remember
they they liked
but then it was also around the same
time that we started talking about the
which i believe is the next episode once
when's the one where um
where you guys pretend to be cops
making a mess
making a mess
that's coming up that's gonna be coming
out yeah yeah i can't remember and and
we did like a serpaco thing and i
remember like that script they had
gotten that script and then they had
gotten this one and they were like
could you guys are now starting to
parody things like which is fine yeah
don't do too much don't do much parrot
don't do too much parody because if the
show lasts for a long time and is in
syndication it's not gonna play as well
and if it's die-hard great and if it's
serpaco great because those are big
those are classics but we do kind of get
into like parodying things later on that
we do it again with american idol which
i have to i have to imagine is going to
feel dated oh that show's still on buddy
yeah but it's not like the cultural
juggernaut that it was that got it all
the time and so no but there's about 500
000 competition competition shows out
there where it's people sitting behind a
table just totally but we're doing we're
actually imitating the actual character
we could talk about that when we when we
get there yeah that's right but yeah i
think it was a good move to not
well not parody someone sp speaking of
parodying though one of my favorite
lines in this episode
and i do love that we did this is uh is
when danny pulls the gun out
falcon yes which for those in the know
was you know so clearly frank had seen
the made for or the edited for tv
version of die hard because the actual
line in the movie is yippie kaye
[ __ ]
and you can't say that on tv so the tv
edit was yippie kaye mr falcon yeah mr
factor and it was like a different voice
like it wasn't bruce willis so it was
like yep
mr belkin it was like the
you know the engineer like was like oh
[ __ ] we missed one he never said oh i i
got it
i can do it i'll do it mr falcon
too close to the mic and
yeah yippee kaye mr falcon i just wonder
how that's there's got to be a better
substitute for [ __ ] than mr
falcon there isn't
that's the greatest
i wonder if you could not even mother
falcon like it could have been a mother
falcon you know i do like the decision
at the time that was like we can't cut
this out it is the it this is the the
premiere line yeah the signature line of
the movie that's right so we can't cut
it out but we gotta mix it up
and then they made that decision
probably last minute and it was mr
falcon
does that cut exist somewhere it has to
right what on earth
can you say that's not [ __ ] in
that situation mother trucker
awful mother sucker
okay
[Music]
they won't let you do it they won't let
you do it mister yeah
mr falcon
all right
yeah right
can we hear that again
oh
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] man you've got a good memory
that you remember that that was like
that that there was something off about
the accident well that was just yeah
that one that one stuck i don't have a
commemorative unit okay
as we've clearly established
well uh can we also talk about the fact
that uh after he says yipikay mr falcon
and pulls the gun out he is holding a
revolver
which presumably only carries
at most six shots he fires that gun i
think i counted 13 times
there's 13 gunshots that come out of
that thing
really yeah yeah i don't know how i
don't know if we just i don't know if we
got in there and we were just like [ __ ]
it it's like it needs to keep going in
order for us to edit the sequence the
way we want to edit i have a big memory
of that exact thing where we're like he
needs to keep doing it for the to give
ryan the time to like have to and it's
yeah yeah
start to fall off the building oh i
think we're talking about in die hard no
no no no in our show no no no no
i mean we've established that there's no
rules right like i think no die and die
hard no
no because that would have been what are
the rules yeah we'll get to that one too
yeah yeah i don't know for like not for
a while months and months and months you
know for some time yeah yeah
uh what else about this episode guys or
what if what what else you mad about you
you know daylight savings are there any
other time related issues that you want
to talk about like uh
i'm looking forward to it being brighter
longer
and everybody is yeah everybody when do
we spring forward because we can't get
rid of the sun with the sun no matter
how much glenn hates it we have to
embrace it it just
does this happen to you guys and you
know i i
so it
i don't like the sun when it's on me and
i'm not
intending to do something that's like if
i'm at the beach and the sun is on me of
course i'm like oh nice cool you know or
if i'm like super cold
and the sun's warming me up but if i'm
in a situation
where you know like i'm standing around
and and the [ __ ] sun's just on me and
i'm like i'm just trying to have a
conversation or i'm like you know doing
something in the yard or something and
the sun's on me i don't like it you get
angry no need what if this is me it
actually heats me up like i get like i
get sure get off me
it drives me crazy actually you [ __ ]
j is this is it
i had a similar experience like i don't
know
ten years ago when when we were getting
into surfing or seeing if we could learn
how to surf when we were in venice and i
remember i was just terrible and i
couldn't get it i was just getting
killed by waves and i remember at one
point i just turned and a wave was
coming in that was that was like about
to crash on me and i just [ __ ] bump
and like which i know is like ridiculous
and then i was so pissed off that i was
angry at the ocean right what was the
wave i was dissolved
just it just it was
it worked
but i remember being like
this is a real concern because you are
now angry at the ocean and look the
ocean's going to win well by the way
yeah ocean ocean winds our ancestors you
know they would have said well it's not
you know they would have been mad at
poseidon yeah you know for sending that
way that you couldn't surf you know you
so you could have you could have punched
the wave and said damn you poseidon or
triton or whoever's in charge of the
ocean would have made me feel a little
bit better right yeah which dennis
reynolds at some point should definitely
[Laughter]
even say damn you besides damn you
poseidon yeah blame it on poseidon i i
did
out final wave we should do an episode
where we travel to hollywood i feel like
that would be a really fun episode the
gang goes to hollywood
we should maybe we're going to pitch a
tv show idea or our characters are going
to pitch an idea you know we got an idea
for something
and we decided we're like
that you can watch in real time you
could rewind charlie me pitching it
glenn kind of yes ending and charlie
just being like
i'll say i'll spare you guys though
yeah well we should go somewhere where
we where we can go get well we could go
back to the shore i guess but we've
already done that yeah you know what i
mean but there's there is something
about
i'm just trying to figure out how to get
that scene in there because i do think
it would be funny to punch a wave and
call out to call you know be angry at
poseidon
that that is that is pretty [ __ ]
funny yeah or angry at the sun hey
speaking of speaking of uh sea gods um
isn't it interesting that aquaman uh has
a uh what are those things called a
trident a trident
but it's got like six prongs on it it
doesn't have three no it's like a it's
like a it's like a a sixth
yeah sex
he's having more fish to eat does he eat
fish is he he isn't no he's not he knows
eat fish no he talks to
hmm [ __ ] yeah but i don't think he's a
predatory fish i think he he talks to
him he can fish food
those little flakes on the top of the
ocean
yeah
he turns up and just
yeah
yeah you feed you feed him the same way
you'd feed a goldfish i have not seen
aquaman i don't think i will it's great
but he likes to like spiderman yeah like
it's good i haven't seen him
is it the same story he's in high school
and he gets bit by a spider no no it's
not an origins okay why are all the new
spider-man movies about him being you
know whatever distance he is from from
his home
yeah homecoming far from home yeah um
yeah far from home like i can't get home
i'm not home now but call me later
eight legs and you can't make your way
home
you should be able to get home eight
times fast what is he gonna have eight
like four times faster he always has two
well
yeah no i always thought it would be
funny to to do a movie about somebody
that gets bit by radioactive spider
starts to get all the powers of the
spider and it's all good but then he
never stops turning into a spider i
guess that's what the flies is that's
the fly well but he never has any pat he
never has any cool powers he does what's
his [ __ ] crazy strong remember he's
just like oh crazy strong and then he's
like very virile and women find him
interactive because he's a half fly for
some reason and then he touched me
i love you i like it is that what the
expression looking fly came from
i believe so yeah yeah right yeah yeah
yeah and then and then
the real turn the real turn happens when
and then he can like well then he can
throw up on stuff and he can he can
digest things outside of his body that's
a cool power
well it was like acid now see i that's a
power i would like
no but have it just have that then
dissolve the food so i don't have to
chew it and then i can just you know
slurp it up
that'd be cool if i could metabolize
sugar the way jeff goldblum's character
can in the fly that'd be pretty sweet
right to be able to metabolize sugar
that well
go ahead what are those what are those
other powers
that's different and then it starts to
get dark then he goes then it goes dark
when he turns into a [ __ ] flock
and then he's begging do you remember
the end of that movie
so good uh where he holds the
the guy's got the shotgun yeah i need it
i don't even remember barely i just
remember him like if it was his
who who's the um female who the love
interest because the show is genius
right yeah so it might be gina davis who
at the end
is like
shooting the shotgun and then she puts
it up and like she lowers it and he's
like almost defeated and he
picks up the shotgun and puts it to his
head yeah like he wants to be killed and
then david cronenberg was like well now
we have to show it yeah because he's
david cronenberg and that that fly head
just [ __ ] explodes
he's got a thing for exploding heads
that dave and crow david cronenberg done
why didn't they just get a big wall of
like a sweet smelling sticky paper
right right and just stick a supply
paper into some flat paper yeah because
because because he has the mind of a man
and the body of a fly or does his mind
also start turning into well he has the
mind of a man but the desires of a fly
does that make sense
so he can think like a man but his
desires off as is often the case with a
man his desires take over and he can't
control himself so yes he would go
straight to that mind and your desires
are somehow disconnected when i'm saying
mine are i'm saying all men are
as as our flaws and that's a fact
that's a fact cut that
[Laughter]
can i uh can i take this opportunity to
hold you guys hostage and ask you some
questions from reddit you're so on theme
i
you're gonna ask us so i put a post on
reddit asking people for questions that
they wanted to ask you on the podcast
yeah and i have a couple of them show
you guys an answer okay we'll do a
lightning round um
what's the story behind the backwards
talking audio clip at the end of each
episode
why do we do it backwards i have no idea
i think it was an arbitrary decision i
think i think we thought it was funny to
make a brown joke and then we were no
the first one was the first one wasn't
brown what was the first one you're
stupid for playing this forward oh
that's what we really wanted to dig in
on like telling the audience they were
dumb they were idiots for watching
it was like a little a little joke a
little prank yeah and then it was a
prank and then it became a theme and
then it became a theme
who has this dennis sex doll where is it
oh where is that i don't know
are you worried about it you know that
was an expensive prop wasn't that a
super expensive prop yeah
we wanted it done
made really well no but somebody's got
it no we reached out to you think about
that i don't think it was a sex style
though right like wasn't it no like so
we reached out to a sex doctor you can
treat it like one
that was way too expensive to actually
make it uh
and actually
it was also two like those things were
like too heavy yeah
i think if you have one of those you
gotta like put it on like a little dolly
cart to move it around
and we had scenes where we were like
carrying it and you know so
we had we had just the pops yeah we just
built like a dummy and then
put a reel did you do a cast for your
head like a mold like um no actually i
think i probably should have because
that probably would have been better but
um what they actually did was they did
some sort of like a i don't know 3d
like i remember i had to just sit
like this and they did like a thing
yeah like a 3d scan yeah and then and
then i did it with different facial
expressions and then they and then it
looked like someone else if you had it
would you [ __ ] it
i most definitely would not i know for
absolutely certain
uh who has the duster
does anybody say
in a wardrobe
warehouse yeah with all our other
costumes it's all being um held for the
smithsonian at some point right yeah
from one understand we've gotten many
letters from the smithsonian like when
can we get our hands on this and we're
like oh no we're still doing the show
they're like you are
yeah okay
jesus let us know when you're done
christ almighty exactly
yeah the last question is um any episode
ideas that you guys wanted to do and fx
just said flat out now
i don't think so no no no no they've
been great partners never yeah way
i mean
no
what was the deal with the the the
episode what was the episode that we did
in season
i i can't remember was it season six
yeah season six that we scrapped
and why did we scrap it you remember and
then oh yeah which we then and then we
turned it into matt gets that yeah i
don't remember it was one with avatar
like we had avatars for ourselves
and uh and the other storyline i don't
remember what the other storyline was
but the reason was because we thought it
didn't work and we scrapped it right i
mean yeah yeah fx didn't want to scrap
it they're like what no because then we
write a lot of money monetize it over
the course of the night and we said well
yeah we'll work it into you won't waste
your money yeah they've been they've let
us do whatever we want they've been good
partners yeah yeah they've been good
sorry i wish we had a more fun answer
yeah sorry yeah yeah got that
they also asked that since you guys are
doing the video podcast now are they
going to see dong
there was that question asked a few
times yeah a few times there's a thong
right up there on the wall oh that's
true how much dong you need
well you might see a ding
from time to time i don't know yeah
the room's pretty cold you're going to
get more dangerous yeah this room is
freezing they're all just dings right
now
it doesn't matter how much you've got
cold man i don't know for freezing in
here yeah
oh you got some press to do some press
and by the time people hear this it's
that rave reviews pal oh really yeah my
dad saw it he did he did he cleaned your
dad yeah he saw it almost right away he
texted me said i really enjoyed it and
then i forward that on to uh charlie to
you know big big his head up it's good
i'm happy with it it's uh
you know that's funny biggest head up um
i did like uh
mary elizabeth showed me an email
the other day that my mom had sent to
her she was like and
she wrote on it
really enjoyed charlie in uh i was like
on the kelly clarkson show and i sang
like midnight train to georgia or
whatever she's like really enjoyed his
performance but don't tell him i don't
want his head to get too big
and i just summed up
now we're getting it now we're getting
into something that's the whole reason
you're probably a performer isn't that
amazing that's
could have been a joke
um
but i don't think that's funny
your mom your mom she ain't but my dad's
funny but
yeah she's lovely but i don't know her
to be funny
not that funny yeah let's get her on the
podcast oh no ask her about that yeah
yeah yeah
i wonder why
what's that all about huh yeah i don't
know i mean my mom grew up
around uh parents who were who were very
like
don't talk about yourself you know
always be humble you know almost to the
point of like
if you want something don't ask for it
if you need something don't ask for it
that's a very act like everything's okay
all the time
yes yes like my microgravity
it's like it's a withholding kind of
thing which is like not too much
pleasure not too much disappointment
right let's never get out of the comfort
zone of neutral because that this is
safe and anything beyond that is
potentially you know love let's stay
yellow no yeah no let's let's stay here
because this is this is this is
dangerous because it's always going to
end and
yeah yeah if you never go for this
you're less likely to for the listener
you're
lifting your hand up and down highs and
lows highs high is dangerous low is also
dangerous yeah yeah even
i will say just to not totally throw my
mom under the bus that she did
eventually email me and say that but it
may have only been because mary
elizabeth emailed her back and be like
you should probably just shake that song
and tell yourself how much you enjoyed
it that's what she did yeah but she did
tell you god bless her yeah
do you think she was writing it like
this like
just like he's like pain having to type
it yeah
what about just calling you and like
saying it as opposed to typing it i
don't know well it's a whole thing okay
it's a whole east coast thing man yeah
my mom doesn't like holding the phone up
to her i'm like just get headphones man
like she's like man it's like it hurts
my neck to hold the phone up so i that's
why i never call you
episodes with our character's parents
are so goddamn funny because the
parent-child relationship it's hilarious
hilarious
there's a lot of there's a lot of stuff
in there yeah a lot of stuff
a lot of fun stuff in there especially
my mom on the show like how she always
annoys my character
uh yeah and how your your mom is by far
the worst and yet you're like convinced
that she loved like you love the [ __ ]
out of it oh yeah yeah absolutely adore
her well because she loves me right back
mrs mac loves her mcdonald's
i'm gonna give a [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's something right i don't give
a [ __ ] we should definitely do an
episode where mrs max is trying to spray
you with vinegar
for some reason yeah but the one where
we're dennis punches away but you're
getting sprayed with all right we gotta
get you're covering yourself in vinegar
to
in my face to get hurt me away from her
but i think she's doing it to like help
my tan yeah yeah to help your tan yeah
we could do one where there's like a
city pool that has a wave machine so
that we're like all just stop about the
wave machine
you know what i mean
your mom's there and she's spraying you
down and you're you're you're the most
excited about the wave machine but then
it turns on you and then yes i'm talking
about the high the high of being like
i'm so excited i've always wanted to
surf you know what i mean i've always
wanted to get out there on those big
waves this is a great way to do it yeah
you know and then the low of discovering
that the wave has far more power than
you can control
but the only reason i'm pitching the
city pool is because we've already done
an ocean episode but we've already done
it we've done we've done it and we've
done a water bar
oh god damn it well i think we did it uh
yeah do we have any other questions or
jokes and tapped into my parent child
relationship
i'm gonna go get a hot tub because jesus
christ
it's cold in here
okay look at that we're gonna go get
[Music]
you